on this episode I talk snapcash the
Thank You economy and what would I do
with my children on social media in the
future yeah I know I said medium weird
media you ask questions and I answer
them this is the askgaryvee show
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
welcome to episode 44 thank you of the
askgaryvee show before I get into the
questions today first of all I just want
to thank everybody for the birthday and
anniversary wishes had an amazing
weekend with Lizzie Lizzie I love you
great time off the grid back on the
grind ready to close out 2014 with a
bang the March - 40 years old is on and
I'm very very focused a couple things
one if you're watching this today on
Tuesday November 18th what are we 18th I
will be on the Seth Meyers show tonight
so set your DVR or stay up to 12:05
Eastern Time I don't know what it is on
the other coasts because the East Coast
is the Best Coast and 2:30 interesting
development out of Airbnb nobody asked
me this question but I figured once in a
while I want to rant about things you're
being be going into print magazine I
think called pineapple I've been a
little off the grid I've got to answer
this snapcash question and I haven't
really been played yet so but I'm really
really interesting move to me something
I want to address with everybody I'm
very fond when the new world goes whole
world I love when Warby Parker and
Birchbox an investment of mine for
disclosure open up retail stores I love
when Airbnb makes a print magazines
CNET making a print magazine you know
I'm one who you know kind of like pounds
on traditional media but if the cost
structure is right and the strategy is
right for Airbnb as they continue to
grow they're now trying to get to that
final step which is broad awareness and
a print magazine in supermarkets across
the country or Barnes and Noble's is a
way for them to get to that 45 to 75
year old that is not as savvy and maybe
that cost of printing on trees might
bring them value and so to me I like the
convergence of the new world going into
the old world versus the old world going
into the new world
Tyler asks do you still think the Thank
You economy will self-destruct in 2015
our brands living up to your predictions
/ Thank You Connie expectations
Tylar once again and I talk about it all
the time
I think things are gonna happen sooner
than they become my prediction and Thank
You economy was that people would
understand this and then everybody would
do it and by 2015 it would get ruined
I am so off on that prediction it's
borderline embarrassing you know d-roc I
don't know can you like take my face
right now and give me like rosy cheeks
like can you make my face red right now
because I'm so embarrassed by how off I
am because to part one people just
haven't adopted the Thank You economy
and thus if they haven't adopted it and
scaled and ruin it how can it be over
right and so it might take a lot longer
it may take forever more importantly the
people that do attack the world in a t
ye world are getting dividends I'm
getting those emails but it has not been
the landslide that I had hoped for the
consumer so you know my prediction was
obnoxiously off one it may not happen at
scale because companies are just
heartless and just don't understand
the financial benefit and listen I'm
heartless I mean it's all about the
wallet with t ye I mean to me it's this
is how you do business and too it's not
enough scale or ruined yet people are
still flabbergasted and excited when a
business acknowledges them or does
something half-assed caring hey Gary
this is Kyle at jock nerd and Ruby it's
two and a half and I was wondering in
the future how are you going to treat
social media with your children oh no
don't hide hi hey Kyle
Ruby you know it's been interesting
Lizzy and I look it's hard to find
pictures of Lizzy on the Internet
let alone you know all full-blast and
Misha and Xander are even more of a rare
commodity you know I'm not sure I mean
obviously I have a partner in crime in
this in this answer Lizzy you know is
very much the co-ceo of the household I
would I'd like to think on the CLO
sometimes I'm just like you know the
maintenance man no I mean the truth is
we communicate a lot about this
you know I'm a counter-puncher I talk a
lot about that I react to the time for
me to predict where socials gonna be or
technology but what I do know is one
thing it's amazing to watch you know 13
year old girl behavior where they're
spending 45 minutes on the lighting and
the angle on an Instagram photo and then
if it doesn't get enough likes in the
first three minutes they take it down so
clearly self-esteem is very wrapped up
in these things and every parent loves
their child so much that you want to
keep them away from bullying and being
made fun of or getting into things too
early in their lives I have the extra
pressure in my opinion of deciding to
raise my children in Manhattan where an
eight year old Maps more like a 17 year
old in many other parts of the country
and so it you know it's a challenge and
it's something I think a lot about and
something I care a lot about I'm not
sure exactly how we're gonna handle it I
think we're gonna handle it by you know
instilling an enormous amount of love
into our children it's very important
for us to establish a foundation of who
they are we've been spending a lot of
time of like mission statements and like
key pillars that we want to instill of
how we want them to act how how we want
them to treat others is very important
to me imposing enormous self esteem into
them is important to me and I think that
to me you know there's new dynamics but
it's still always the same and and what
I mean by that is the core pillars of
good parenting haven't changed since the
beginning of time there's new dynamics
you know those things are probably more
important than ever having more
self-esteem more perseverance better
manners all those things probably matter
more than ever and so I'm gonna just try
to deliver tried-and-true things to my
kids much like I do with business the
world changes but the principles of
patience and and believing your people
and establishing infrastructure and
playing the long game yeah I'm you know
I've said it before on this show you
know a tortoise in a hares costume you
know I believe in old school things like
that and so I'm just gonna instill
really good core fundamentals and let
the outside world evolve because I can't
control it and just instill my
children's and into that world most
prepared and best positioned this
exceed everybody asks what do you think
about snapcash all right I get it you
want to know about snapcash just watch
the video nice job nice production look
I think this continues this is why I
invested in venmo four years ago the the
thought of payment transfers amongst
people in a paperless cashless world is
very important and to layer it into a
social network what I like about it for
snapchat is they're getting in very
early what I mean by very early is not
into the game very early in one's age to
create the behavior because snapchat has
a heavy 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 year old
demo they can capture a lot of that
behavior I always thought that Facebook
I remember thinking that the social
network I wanted to build when Facebook
was blowing it up was one that was
around your license because I wanted to
get the people before they went to
college and I thought like we start a
social network where your license was
your gateway in that there was something
there and and that's what snapchat has
done it's gone earlier
it creates behavior look cryptocurrency
Apple pay this kind of stuff with Square
and snapchat if I'm a traditional
financial service I'm very concerned
about the enormous innovation over the
last 24 months invading on my turf and
if I'm a consumer I'm extremely happy
because competition breeds enormous
innovation and the number one thing we
love is time and I see a lot of things
in the financial world saving us time
now saving us time to go into our wallet
and take this out and take out cash I
actually have to give receipts to Matt
you know so that's good and you know or
this you know taking out a credit card
and swiping it takes time all these
things are much quicker in this world
speed my friends in sports and in
business really matters because we value
time the most would be time to get a
watch question of the day what is your
number one most recent app download what
is the last app you downloaded on your
phone I'm gonna give you my answer I'm
not quite sure
I think hold on I want to give you the
truth hold on
screwing up the show I know there was
something very very recent that I liked
I'm playing with swipe swipe is a fairly
recent for me
let me show one more time swipe it all
right there so uh s WIP e check that out
thanks for watching 44 little chill kind
of like post vacation intensity you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
check out Seth Meyers tonight and
subscribe to the show
don't forget the podcast oh crap wait
subscribe I need subscriptions because I
can't push this many right hooks in
social so subscribe